HELP THE PEOPLE OF UKRAINE, GO
TO CNN.COM/IMPACT.
YOU WILL IMPACT YOUR WORLD.
JOINING US NOW, LEON PANETTA, HE
IS FORMER SECRETARY OF DEFENSE,
FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE CIA.
ALSO, SERVED AS THE WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF UNDER PRESIDENT
BILL CLINTON.
IMPRESSIVE RESUME BY LEON
PANETTA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
SECRETARY, FOR JOINING US.
YOU PROBABLY HEARD THIS BUT THE
CURRENT U.S. SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE, LLOYD AUSTIN, SAYS
RUSSIA IS NOW MAKING INCREMENTAL
GAINS IN THE SOUTH.
YOU SEE SIGNS THAT UKRAINE'S
MILITARY, THOUGH, IS STARTING TO
FALTER UNDER THIS ENORMOUS AND
BRUTAL RUSSIAN OFFENSIVE?
>> WELL, THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT THE RUSSIANS HAVE
OVERWHELMING STRENGTH THERE AND
THEY ARE TRYING TO APPLY IT IN
EVERY AREA, PARTICULARLY NOW IN
THE SOUTH.
SO, LLOYD AUSTIN IS PROBABLY
RIGHT.
THEY ARE MAKING SOME INCREMENTAL
STEPS TO -- TO REALLY MOVE THE
BALL HERE IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE
TO TAKE OVER AREAS.
BUT I THINK THE UKRAINIANS ARE
STILL PUTTING UP A HELL OF A
FIGHT.
THEY'RE -- THEY REALLY HAVE
STALLED THE RUSSIAN ARMY IN A
NUMBER OF WAYS.
THEY'VE DELAYED THEIR ABILITY TO
MOVE FORWARD.
THE RUSSIANS ARE USING,
OBVIOUSLY, THESE MISSILES.
THEY ARE USING ARTILLERY.
THEY'RE ENGAGED IN WANTON
KILLING OF INNOCENT MEN, WOMEN,
AND CHILDREN.
I STILL THINK THAT THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE A FIGHTING
CHANCE HERE TO BE ABLE TO --
TO -- TO SEND A CLEAR MESSAGE TO
PUTIN THAT HE'S A LOSER IN THIS
WAR.
>> U.S. OFFICIALS ARE CONFIRMING
TODAY -- AND YOU HAVE HEARD THIS
AS WELL -- THAT RUSSIA IS NOW
USING THESE HYPERSONIC MISSILES.
THESE ARE WEAPONS THAT TRAVEL AT
MAC FIVE SPEEDS AND THEY ARE
USING THESE MISSILES INSIDE
UKRAINE.
HOW SIGNIFICANT OF A DEVELOPMENT
IS THIS?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WE -- WE SEEM
TO BE WORRIED AND WE SHOULD BE
ABOUT ESCALATING THE WAR THERE
IN UKRAINE.
I UNDERSTAND THOSE CONCERNS BUT
PUTIN IS NOT WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
BY USING HYPERSONIC MISSILES
LIKE THIS, HE IS ESCALATING THE
WAR IN UKRAINE.
AND USING THE KIND OF MISSILES
THAT NOT ONLY TRAVEL AT
SUPERSONIC SPEEDS BUT CAN AVOID
DETECTION ON THE GROUND.
THIS IS A -- THIS IS A WEAPON
THAT CAN REALLY, ULTIMATELY
ESCALATE THIS BATTLE BECAUSE WE
CAN'T ALLOW THOSE KINDS OF
HYPERSONIC MISSILES TO BE ABLE
TO NOW TARGET AREAS WHEREVER
THEY WANT AND NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BRING 'EM DOWN.
THIS IS -- I THINK THIS IS A
DANGEROUS ESCALATION IN THE WAR.
>> YEAH, THAT'S WHAT I HAVE BEEN
HEARING ALL DAY RIGHT NOW.
THIS COULD REALLY, REALLY
ESCALATE WHAT'S ALREADY A
HORRIBLE SITUATION.
AS YOU KNOW, THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY --
HE WANTS DIRECT PEACE TALKS WITH
RUSSIA.
BUT DO YOU SEE A SCENARIO IN
WHICH THAT HAPPENS?
PUTIN DOESN'T SEEM TO WANT ANY
KIND OF PEACE TALKS RIGHT NOW
WITH THE UKRAINIANS.
>> WELL, WOLF, LOOK.
WE -- WE KNOW ONE THING, THAT
PUTIN -- PUTIN OPERATES BY
FORCE.
HE'S BEEN DOING THAT MOST OF HIS
LIFE. AND IT'S EXACTLY WHAT HE'S
DOING IN UKRAINE NOW IS THE
WANTON APPLICATION OF MILITARY
FORCE.
AND VERY FRANKLY, THE ONLY THING
HE UNDERSTANDS IS THE USE OF
FORCE.
SO, THAT'S WHY IT'S ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL THAT WE PROVIDE AS MUCH
WEAPONRY AND ASSISTANCE AND
MILITARY SUPPORT AS POSSIBLE TO
THE UKRAINIANS RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE THEIR ABILITY TO
CONTINUE THIS FIGHT -- THAT,
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE --
KILLING RUSSIANS AND STALLING
THEIR ADVANCES -- THAT MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE SENDS A MESSAGE TO
PUTIN THAT HE'S IN TROUBLE.
IF THE UKRAINIANS WANT TO
NEGOTIATE AND -- AND OBVIOUSLY,
THEY SHOULD TRY TO NEGOTIATE --
BUT THEY NEED LEVERAGE.
AND THE BEST LEVERAGE THEY CAN
GET IS BY GETTING THE UKRAINIANS
THE HELP THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
FIGHT THE RUSSIANS.
>> AS YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT BIDEN
ON FRIDAY IN A TWO-HOUR PHONE
CONVERSATION WITH CHINA'S XI
JINPING -- HE SPOKE OF
CONSEQUENCES, SHOULD THE CHINESE
DECIDE TO ACTUALLY HELP THE
RUSSIAN INVASION.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT CHINA TO DO
AS A RESULT OF THAT PHONE CALL?
>> YOU KNOW, MY SENSE IS THAT --
AND -- AND I HAVE TALKED TO
PEOPLE WITH SOME KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
THE IMPACT THAT THE UKRAINIAN
WAR HAS HAD WITH REGARDS TO
CHINA.
I THINK IT HAS MADE PRESIDENT XI
PAUSE.
UH, AND JUST EXACTLY WHAT HE IS
GOING TO DO.
I THINK HE IS GOING TO BE VERY
CAREFUL, AND WALK A FINE LINE
HERE.
TRYING TO OBVIOUSLY PROVIDE SOME
WORDS OF ENCOURAGEMENT TO
RUSSIA.
BUT IN TERMS OF ACTIONS, I THINK
CHINA KNOWS THAT IF THEY TAKE
STEPS TO PROVIDE MILITARY
WEAPONS OR SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
AID, THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
LABELED A PARIAH JUST LIKE PUTIN
IS LABEL ADD PARIAH.
LABELED A PARIAH.
AND FRANKLY, CHINA CARES ABOUT
CHINA.
THEY KNOW THAT IF THEY DO THAT,
IT WILL IMPACT ON THEIR ECONOMY.
IT'LL IMPACT ON -- ON EVERYTHING
THEY'VE TRIED TO DO IN ORDER TO
INFLUENCE OTHER COUNTRIES TO
WORK WITH CHINA.
I DON'T THINK THEY WANT TO PAY
THAT PRICE, SO I'M GLAD THAT THE
PRESIDENT DID THAT.
AND I THINK WE JUST GOT TO MAKE
VERY CLEAR THAT IF THEY DO THAT,
THEY ARE GOING TO PAY A PRICE.
>> THEY CERTAINLY WILL.
YOU -- I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HEARD
ABOUT THIS BUT UKRAINE'S FORMER
PRESIDENT JUST A FEW HOURS AGO
RIGHT HERE ON CNN SAID HE THINKS
PRESIDENT BIDEN SHOULD TRAVEL TO
KYIV THIS WEEK.
HE IS GOING TO BRUSSELS FOR THE
NATO SUMMIT.
IF YOU WERE STILL IN THE OVAL
OFFICE WORKING WITH THE
PRESIDENT, WOULD YOU ADVISE
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO MAKE THAT
TRIP?
IT CLEARLY WOULD BE PRETTY
RISKY.
>> WELL, AS A FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF, YOUR -- YOUR PRIMARY
CONCERN IS PROTECTING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
AND -- AND I THINK THAT
SHOULD -- SHOULD BE THE PRIMARY
CONCERN AT THIS POINT, WHICH IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE PROTECT THE
PRESIDENT IN EVERY WAY POSSIBLE.
IF THERE IS A WAY FOR HIM TO
MEET WITH ZELENSKYY AND IT'S
SECURE AND CAN BE DONE WITHOUT
JEOPARDIZING THE PRESIDENT'S
SECURITY, I WOULD SAY THAT THEY
SHOULD LOOK AT.
THAT -- THAT POSSIBILITY.
BUT I THINK FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
GO INTO THE MIDDLE OF A WAR ZONE
AT THIS POINT IN TIME, I'D HAVE
TO SAY THAT REALLY MAKES ME VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S
SAFETY.
>> YEAH.
EARLIER, A FEW DAYS AGO, THREE
NATO ALLIES, LEADERS OF THREE
NATO COUNTRIES DID MAKE THAT
RISKY TRIP TO KYIV AND MET WITH
THE UKRAINIAN LEADER.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THE